[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben sie machen heute
matschie als also ich habe matschie ist
das erste mal vor zirka zwei jahren
gegessen hat eine freundin das also
fertig gekauft mitgebracht und ich fand
es ganz cool ist es gewöhnungsbedürftig
denn mochis besteht eigentlich aus einem
seiner teile sind teigmantel aus
klebreis nähe und innen drin gibt es
dann verschiedene füllungen und ganz neu
ist das motto und das machen wir jetzt
passt natürlich zum anstehenden sommer
und ich habe jetzt hier die zutaten für
meinen teil
und er ist auch einfacher als jetzt
vielleicht vermuten wir brauchen auch
nur drei zutaten die wichtigste zutat
ist das klebreis mehr es gibt auch reis
mehl aber ihr müsst unbedingt darauf
achten dass es klebreis mail ist es gebe
ich jetzt in eine große schüssel und
dazu kommt wasser die ganz genauen
mengenangaben steht die unten in der
video beschreibung
das wasser gehe ich mit dazu und zucker
gebe ich auch schon mit dazu und wasser
ist bei mir übrigens lauwarm so
verbindet sich das ganze besser so das
ist die konsistenz nach 30 sekunden hier
dürfen keine klümpchen mehr drin sein
und jetzt gehen wir über zum herd
[Musik]
zu den noch flüssigen teig geben wir
denn eine beschichtete pfanne und jetzt
ist ganz wichtig dass ihr nur die
mittlere stufe nehmen also ich bin
maximal bei stufe 5 von 9
und dann dauert das ganze zehn minuten
ich habe extra die zeit gestoppt zehn
minuten bis ihr diese konsistenz
erreicht also ich zeig euch mal von la
das müsst ihr einfach sehen das kann ich
nie so gut beschreiben also so klebrig
ist dann der teig und wichtig ist dass
ihr eben mit einem teig java oder mit
dem kochlöffel dass ihr da immer wieder
hin und her schiebt mit euch das am
boden nicht anpackt und jetzt möchte ich
mein tag bevor ich das ganze weiter
verarbeitet einfärben das mache ich mit
lebensmittelfarben dafür habe ich mir
hier drei schüsseln bereitgelegt und
werde jetzt den teig ist einmal durch
drei teilen
[Musik]
die farben haben auch so ein bisschen
was mit meiner füllung gleich zu tun
aber das zeige ich euch nachher jetzt
habe ich hier ein bisschen tapioka
stärke wenn ihr die nicht habt dann
könnt ihr auch kartoffelstärke nehme ich
glaube die findet man eher in den
supermärkten aber ich hatte das jetzt da
und gibt es jetzt ja einfach auf meine
arbeitsfläche auch nicht geizen weil es
ist schon ein sehr klebriger teig und
dann verteilen wir einfach unsere drei
tage darüber
[Musik]
so und jetzt lasst er das ganz kurz
auskühlen das habe ich jetzt gemacht so
ungefähr zehn minuten dann könnt ihr
auch darauf tippen und es klebt nicht
mehr so doll
und so ist hier ja weiß bis jetzt nicht
was los ist okay krass ok interessant
dann bin ich mal gespannt wie du es
finden es ganz am ende also wenn man
jetzt folgen das ich nehme mir jetzt mal
eine tankkarte und anteile ich jeden tag
kommt auf antwort ihr große oder kleine
mochis was mache ich durchdrehe dadurch
ich kann ja immer noch rum switchen ich
mache erst mal durch 3
[Musik]
so nachdem ihr dann alle matschie teige
geformt habt einfach medien haben ja
kommen sie einfach also hier müsst euch
auch keinen stress machen ihr müsst euch
nicht bereit allerdings will ich jetzt
kurz hackfleisch und dann geht es weiter
ja es ist aber haben sie hatte keine
ahnung ist wenn du sie hat sich
praktisch mal kurz es wird was ich hole
jetzt und wenn ich das alles wohl müssen
uns natürlich bei allen hat sich ganz
gut zum gefrierfach und dann sehen uns
gleich wieder so jetzt schnappt ihr euch
eure lieblings eiskugeln ich habe mich
für erdbeer vanille und cookie dough
entschieden richtig lecker einfach
mitnimmt portionierer eingeben und dann
langsam verschließen allerdings dürfte
auch nicht soviel hand wärme abgeben
weil das eis schmilzt ja natürlich auch
[Musik]
also ich probiere jetzt mal für euch ich
mir einfach mal vanille ist jetzt
natürlich ein bisschen geschmolzen aber
das erinnert mich ein bisschen an
kaugummi
kann sein aber also diese äußere hülle
einer nicht so von der konsistenz auch
ein bisschen ein kaugummi und in ist
natürlich dass alles was ihr euch
aussucht das soll natürlich ein
hochwertiges als sein dass sollte
lecker schmecken weil da ist der
geschmack ganz klar aber ich persönlich
finde es ganz cool könnte man echt mal
auch zwar mit freunden machen und hat
auch immer im gefrierfach lagern dann
könnt ihr euch immer wenn ihr lust habt
auf mochis könnt ihr euch das raus kam
es geht natürlich auch mit anderen
varianten was hast du für ideen was ist
das ist okay okay okay haben es probiert
jetzt auch ansonsten könnt ihr alle
varianten nehmen
mango maracuja oder schokolade alles was
ihr möchtet ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz
viel freude dann nachmachen und wir
sehen uns dann bei meinem nächsten
rezept für eure krise für die hände
sauber machen und dann gemütlich immer
noch bis dann tschüss
[Musik]